n'a répondu au question
des médias. Est-ce la fin pour
Sunwing? L'avis des agences
de voyage et d
- Une semaine après la tempête
qui a causé l'annulation
de nombreux vols et un temps
des Fêtes cauchemardesque
pour des milliers de voyageurs,
la tête de l'eau. L'entreprise
a annoncé cette semaine sur
vols depuis Régina et Saskatoon
ont été annulés jusqu'à début
février. Son président a déclaré
par communiqué que Sunwing
continuait de faire face à
dedes difficultés opérationnells
sans précédent et regretter
la situation.
qui ont été coincés à l'étranger
pendant des jours, ces excuses
ne suffisent pas.
ÉRIC VALLIERES,
client de Sunwing
- On a aucune confiance
Donc, c'est certain que même
s'ils nous offraient des billets
d'avion, on les prendrait pas.
- Sunwing n'a pas répondu
à notre demande d'entrevue.
sur place au siège social
de l'entreprise, que vous voyez
derrière moi. Les bureaux
étaient fermés. Nous n'avo
un représentant de l'entreprise.
Le manque de communication
de Sunwing pourrait causer
beaucoup de tort au transporteur
aérien selon des experts.
sur la confiance des voyageurs,
une crise e e e celle-là
pourrait être fatale pour
la compagnie aérienne croit ce
spécia
expert en gestion de crise
- Ça, ça veut dire qu'en ayant
un bris de confiance avec
les passagers, non seulement la
valeur de l'entreprise baisse,
gens. Et là, bien, il y a deux
possibilités : soit les
lâchent complètement Sunwing,
puis à ce moment-là, on est
vraiment devant nwnwnwnwnwnwnwn,
qui a des ententes avec certains
hôteliers  c c c choses comme
ça, va se mettre sur le marché.
- Cette propriétaire d'agence
de voyages, elle,
optimiste, même si elle croit
que l'entreprise devra faire
face à d'impasasasasasasasasasa,
d'autant plus qu'elle pourrait
faire l'obououououoursuites.
PATRICIA FARGEON,
propriétaire, Planet France
- Dire "je ne vais plus jamais
voyager avec eux parce que
c'est facile à dire au début,
mais, par la suite, il faut
réaliser que c'est une situation
qui aurait pu arriver à d'autres
compagnies aériennes.
a indiqué par courriel continuer
à travailler pour régler
l'arriéré des vols e
prévu 43, dont 34 ont été
complétés en date d'
L'entreprise affirme que la
plupart, sinon tous ses clients,
devraient être rentrés chez eux
d'ici le 2 janvier.
Ici Andréane Williams, Radio